I want to start by thanking everyone who
is staying at home even in this sunshine
together we are slowing the spread of
this virus and I want to pay a special
tribute today to captain Tom Moore who
at the age of 99 has raised over seven
million pounds so far for NHS charities
by completing a hundred laps of his
garden captain Tom you're an inspiration
to us all and we thank you at the core
of our plan is to protect the NHS from
being overwhelmed so its ability to care
for everybody who needs that care is
always there and is never outmatched by
the ability of the virus to do us harm
that is central to our plan and I'm glad
to say that the spare capacity in
critical care in the NHS today has
reached a new record high of two
thousand six hundred and fifty-seven
vets expanding the NHS faster than the
growth in demand has been a critical
objective throughout this crisis and it
means that every single person who's
accessed NHS care has been able to get
the very best available at no point has
the NHS been unable to offer care to
people suffering from coronavirus now I
know at the start of this crisis some
people said that would be impossible but
so far we've met this objective
throughout and I want to thank all those
involved for their part in this national
effort on the most recent figures three
hundred and thirteen thousand seven
hundred and sixty nine people have now
been tested for coronavirus of these 98
thousand four hundred and seventy six
people have tested positive the number
of patients in hospital with symptoms is
now nineteen thousand five hundred and
twenty nine twelve thousand eight
hundred and sixty-eight people have
sadly died an increase of seven hundred
and sixty-one this all just goes to show
why we can
let up in our efforts we cannot let go
of the hard work that's been done so far
this shared sacrifice and I know it's a
sacrifice is starting to work but we
will not lift these measures until it is
safe to do so everyone who stays at home
is doing their bit
protecting the NHS and saving lives but
while everyone else stays at home to
save lives our health and care workers
go out to work to save lives and today I
want a to focus on social care I want to
set out the next steps in our action
plan for social care that we're
publishing today from the moment of the
emergence of coronavirus we've known
that some of the most vulnerable to this
disease are in social care and we've
been taking action right from the start
we first set out guidance back in
February and today I can tell you what
further steps we're now able to make our
goal throughout has been to protect
residents and to support our 1.5 million
colleagues who work in social care we've
injected an extra 1.6 billion pounds and
as the Chancellor said we will do
whatever it takes this is our plan
first and foremost from the start we've
focused on the need to control the
spread of infection in social care
settings
today we've strengthened the rules so
that all care home residents who are
discharged from hospital will be tested
before being admitted into their care
home will test all symptomatic care home
residents and as I announced last Friday
we've introduced testing for all social
care colleagues and members of their
households who meet who need a test at
the same time we're increasing again PPE
supplies to social care we're creating a
supply logistics and distribution
network of unprecedented scale building
on the PPE plan are set out on Friday
over the next three weeks we'll continue
priority drops to the local resilience
forums
distribute to the social care system
according to local need while we roll
out our new online delivery system for
social care settings this will be
integrated with the NHS supply chain
central PPE
logistical operations with kit shipped
directly to social care providers via
the Royal Mail all of this will
contribute to slowing the spread of
coronavirus within care homes I want
also to enhance support for our social
care workforce one of the things that
I'm most proud of during this terrible
crisis is that people have held health
and social care workers in such high
esteem across the board it's not platt
for the NHS it's clap for our carers and
to take this further we're today
introducing a single brand for social
care to symbolise the entire care
profession this is something I know so
many people in the profession have
called for this badge will be a badge of
honour in a very real sense allowing
social care staff proudly and publicly
to identify themselves just like NHS
staff do with that famous blue and white
logo I know that many businesses will
want to offer the same recognition of
benef benefits as they do wonderfully to
the NHS we've asked the supermarket's to
confirm that social care workers can
have the same priority access and I know
that the public value your work in care
as much as I do I also know that we need
more people to return to social care or
choose to serve for the first time to
make that happen
we're strengthening our national
recruitment campaign with the aim of
recruiting tens of thousands more people
into social care and we will pay for the
initial induction training this is a job
where you have the chance to make a
difference to people's lives every
single day that you go to work and I've
seen as I'm sure we've all seen the
amazing efforts
of good social care I've seen it with
elderly members of my own family I've
seen the tenderness and the dedication
with which people in social care support
our loved ones at their time of greatest
need
everyone knows the job isn't easy
whether supporting people of working age
who are some of the most vulnerable in
society all supporting people and their
families with dignity at the end of
their lives but I know what a fulfilling
profession it is and I know that many
will answer our call there's one other
thing and one other change I want to
make which is giving people the right to
say goodbye one of the important things
that care homes do is support people at
the end of their life sadly even in
normal times each month about 10,000
people die in care homes and our social
care colleagues work incredibly hard to
ensure support for people and dignity to
people at the end of their lives wanting
to be with someone you love at the end
of their life is one of the deepest
human instincts and it's a moment that
will be with you forever
done right it can help those left behind
to cope and it brings comfort to those
who are dying coronavirus of course has
made this much more difficult and I've
been really moved and upset by some of
the heartbreaking stories of people
dying without a loved one nearby as a
father of a 13 year old myself the
reports of Ishmael dying aged 13 without
a parent as his bedside made me weep and
the sight of his coffin being lowered
into a grave without a member of his
family present was too awful so I'm
pleased to say that working with public
health England the care sector and many
others we're introducing new procedures
so we can limit the risk of infection
while wherever possible giving people's
close
loved ones the chance to say goodbye and
we're making crystal clear that it is
unacceptable for advanced care plans
including do not attempt to resuscitate
orders to be applied in a blanket
fashion to any group of people this must
always be a personalized process as it
always has been I want to end by
addressing carers directly as much as
the doctors the nurses the paramedics
you are on the frontline in this battle
I want to thank you for your courage and
your commitment for doing paid or unpaid
formal or informal the work that you do
difficult demanding vitally necessary
and you do it with such love and care
and attention taking on the extra shifts
that might be needed to fill the gaps
left by self isolating colleagues
juggling your own caring
responsibilities very often providing
dignity and comfort to people in some of
the most difficult circumstances we as a
nation stand with you and I say to
everyone watching you can stand with our
carers too by staying at home to protect
the NHS and protect Social Care and save
lives